we want to underscore again that we're
coming to chicago peacefully but whether
we're given permits or not
we're coming netflix blockbuster the
trial of the chicago 7 has received six
oscar nominations
the film which follows a group of
anti-vietnam war protesters
charged with conspiracy and crossing
state lines with intents
in sight of riot at the 1968 democratic
national convention has also reignited a
debate about filmmakers prioritizing
compelling drama
above historical facts
aaron sorkin the movie screenwriter and
director
speaks to the economist asks podcast
about the creative challenges of
dramatizing one of the most notorious
cases in america's history
aaron sorkin welcome to the economist
asks
it's good to be here this story was 14
years in
the making it ended up being more
topical than you could probably have
imagined for a lot of that time why were
you so convinced
that it had this enduring relevance you
know we thought the film was plenty
relevant when we were making it last
winter
we didn't need it to get more relevant
but it did
come last may after the police killings
of george floyd and brianna taylor here
uh protesters took to the streets uh and
they were met in a number of cities
by riot clubs and tear gas uh
again sometimes i've watched cnn their
coverage of the protest
and think you know if you just degraded
the color on this it would look exactly
like the footage we used
from from 1968 and a courtroom drama
also means you have transcripts you have
news footage of tv
interviews from the period to what
degree is this detective work
and for someone like you who likes to
base a lot of your drama
in fact in events but then piece them
together
from the truth of the story from these
different perspectives what's the
balance there between
creative license and kind of what it
says in the documents
the difference that you're talking about
uh
is the difference between a photograph
and a painting and
uh and this is a painting stew between
journalism and art
uh and it's the difference between
accuracy and truth
uh so for example uh
one of the more harrowing moments uh in
the trial and in the film is when bobby
seal gets bound and gagged
uh in the courtroom uh uh the judge has
just had enough of him
orders him to be dragged away by the u.s
marshals and the judge's words
deal with him as he should be dealt with
uh which is taken directly
uh from the transcript but this actually
happened over several days didn't it
yes first for anyone who doesn't know
let me explain
uh in the film he's brought back in he's
bound and gagged uh the judge gives him
one more chance
uh uh if you behave yourself i'll take
the gag off do i have your word that
you'll behave yourself
he nods he stares at the judge and nods
shakes his head back and forth
no um uh and so the judge says fine
let's go ahead and joseph gordon-levitt
is the prosecutor
asked to approach the bench and ask the
judge to grant a mistrial in the case of
bobby seal because the defendant
has been bound and gagged in an american
courtroom uh
and it's granted in reality it took
four days uh uh as you just pointed out
bobby sat in the courtroom for four days
bound and get
before the judge separated him from the
rest of the defendants and gave him his
mistrial so why did i do
uh what i did uh because
i felt that we had landed
the truth of the moment um uh uh the the
most harrowing part
he was this happened uh a bound gag
shackled beaten
uh the whole thing and that to leave
bobby there
and continue the story for four more
days
paying attention to other things it
would start to feel like
it wasn't that big a deal that bobby was
bound and gagged
uh that life goes on uh uh with him
sitting there bound and gag he would
almost
seem like a sight gag in a way
um so i i felt
okay journalistic accuracy he would have
to be there for four days
artistic truth you can check the box
uh and and be done with that because
if you don't you're going to start to
dim that truth uh a little bit you're
going to start to normalize
uh the fact that he's doing so it sounds
like you think the journalistic
accuracy and an artistic truth can be in
conflict
sometimes and sometimes not in other
words
if you can be journalistically accurate
and land that truth too
if you're writing uh if if you're a
reporter covering that trial
um there is a way to write about the
fact that bobby seal has been bound and
gagged in this courtroom for four days
in a way that is equal to uh uh to the
importance
of that uh because because you're
describing it
i can't do that i i have to dramatize
the whole thing
and the the fact is if you gave me some
time
i'm sure i could think of a way to
to to land the the impact of the
journalistically true
version too um
but uh i i made the decision to go this
way
this is a really interesting area when
we tease apart how much we expect
historical drama or particularly
recently rooted historical drama we seem
to be a bit more kind of liberal about
it when it goes back a few centuries
let me give you an example and tell me
what you think and that's where eddie
redmayne as tom hayden reads the list of
vietnam casualties and of course it's
been pointed out
that this happened earlier in the trial
it was david dullinger
not the tom hayden character and it did
include vietnamese names as well as
american ones
now in another context one might say
changing this around missing out the
other the competence as it turned out in
this
conflict on which this drama turns might
be called fake news what's the
difference
okay here it is we have for the whole
film one of the stories we've been
telling
is tom hayden versus abby hoffman right
um kind of a reflection of today's
uh democratic party the tension between
the left and the further left people who
want
incremental change compromise um
uh and people who are tired of
incremental change and
and want revolution tom's thing was can
we please
just behave ourselves while we're in
this courtroom so we can be found not
guilty get back out on the streets and
continue
trying to end up the vietnam war whereas
abby along with jerry um they felt that
their job
every day in the courtroom was to
demonstrate to the judge that they have
no respect
uh for these proceedings at all that
this is the demonstration right now
uh in the courtroom this is the
revolution uh right now and
abby throughout the film is needling
tom questioning his courage
uh and bravery so
our final moment in the starkest
possible terms
the judge says to uh hayden if you make
your final remark brief
and respectful uh uh and without any
political content
i will show mercy on you before the
sentencing
we even skip over the guilty or not
guilty part because we know they've
already
uh uh lost so the triumphant moment is
going to be hayden
not being brief not being respectful and
having as much political content
as you can imagine through the simple
act
of instead of giving a political speech
reading 4794
names out loud into the trial transcript
okay that was the truth that i wanted to
land that hayden was in fact
incredibly courageous um uh and that
at the at the witching hour at the
moment of truth
he was what abby said he was on the
stand a badass of an american
patriot uh have him also reading names
of
north vietnamese soldiers if you do it
earlier in the trial
if you have dellinger do it none of that
much more important truth lance you've
done a journalistically accurate
uh version of the trial of the chicago
seven
which is basically dramatizing a
wikipedia page
and uh it's just not what i wanted to do
with the story
so everyone has their own inner compass
uh there are things i wouldn't dream of
changing uh uh for any reason uh
and there are things i have no problem
uh working with as a dramatist without
feeling like i'm perverting history at
all
great to talk to you aaron talking thank
you for joining us you bet i could talk
to you
you can listen to the full interview in
our podcast the economist asks
every week we talk to a high profile
figure click the link opposite to find
this episode and
thanks for watching
[Music]
you